Die afrikanische schweinepest rückt immer näher an deutschland heran bereits tausende infizierte tiere sind aus osteuropa gemeldet worden die neuesten
infektionsherde in polen sind gerade einmal 300 bis 400 kilometer von deutschland entfernt ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle facts zur afrikanischen schweinepest
Wie groß ist die gefahr dass
Sie solche jetzt auch nach deutschland eingeschleppt wird und wie wollen die behörden die pest unter kontrolle bekommen jetzt in kriegs und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
70 prozent aller wildschweine in deutschland müssen getötet werden und schon jetzt sind allein in bayern
13.000 wildschweine erlegt worden
Zitat die infektion ist eine reale und ernsten bedrohung für deutschland so die einschätzung von thomas mettenleiter präsident
des friedrich-loeffler-instituts für tiergesundheit
konkret spricht er von dem
afrikanischen schweinepest virus das ausschließlich haus und wildschweine befällt ein ausbruch in deutschland hätte
katastrophale folgen für die landwirtschaft deutschland
Zählt zu den größten schweinefleisch produzenten weltweit die übertragung kann auf verschiedenen wegen passieren beispielsweise
Durch den kontakt von kranken und gesunden tieren aber auch indirekt durch die fütterung mit abfällen die infizierte
schweinefleisch enthalten als erste symptome sind dann hohes fieber durchfall erbrechen und
koordinierte bewegung zu beobachten
Oft sterben die tiere innerhalb von 48 stunden das große problem es gibt keinen impfstoff bislang schaffen es die behörden tatsächlich
Nicht die seuche einzudämmen
in der tschechischen stadt flint
beispielsweise wurden drei bekämpfung stone eingerichtete dieses vorgehen galt lange als vorbild auch für die deutschen behörden doch trotzdem wurden
im januar zehn infizierte wildschweine
Außerhalb des gebietes gefunden und ja klar
elektrozäune können zwar großflächig eingesetzt werden doch können nicht ganze straßen und dörfer komplett abgeriegelt werden das gebiet liegt übrigens nur
300 kilometer von der grenze zu sachsen und bayern entfernt und jetzt ist ein neuer
infektionsherd entdeckt worden
Im nördlichen polen dort wo im januar alleine 312 fälle registriert wurden also der am stärksten
betroffene eu staat und auch hier ist die deutsche grenze nicht weit mecklenburg vorpommern liegt eben etwa nur
400 kilometer entfernt und es werden immer mehr fälle gemeldet
4140 fälle waren es im jahr 2017 östlich von deutschland also unter anderem in polen den baltischen staaten und tschechien
Im ganzen jahr 2014 waren es nur 3 104 fälle allein. Im januar 2018 sind es aber allein schon
359 fälle fest steht also die ausbreitung des virus hat nicht an dynamik verloren
Im gegenteil expertinnen gehen davon aus dass sich der virus erreger in ländern wie ost polen litauen und estland
mittlerweile schon etabliert hat und er so innerhalb einer schweine population immer weiter an neue tiere weitergeben
Das gegenteil wäre wünschenswert gewesen nämlich dass sich die krankheit tod läuft doch es ist fast unmöglich
Die solche in den wildbeständen unter kontrolle zu bekommen denn auch wenn weniger tiere an der afrikanischen schweinepest erkranken als an der maul und klauenseuche
halten sich die erreger sehr lange in den infizierten
kadavern noch die experten sind sich einig das größte risiko dass die solche auch nach deutschland eingeschleppt
wird liegt beim menschen und nicht bei der übertragung von tier zu tier
kontaminierte schweineprodukte gelang innerhalb von kürzester zeit
Viele tausend kilometer weit die ausbruchs geschwindigkeit bei der tier zu tier übertragung liegt nach angaben ja bisher bei
So maximal 30 kilometern pro jahr
Fest steht jedenfalls der ausbruch der seuche in deutschland hätte fatale auswirkungen auf die tiergesundheit und den handel zitat die volkswirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
auswirkungen eines ausbruchs der afrikanischen schweinepest sind kaum vorstellbar bereits das auftreten
im wildschweinbestand würde bedeuten dass kein
schweinefleisch mehr in drittländer also in länder außerhalb der eu exportiert werden kann so der bauernverband in einer offiziellen mitteilung
das friedrich-loeffler-institut für tiergesundheit warnt eindringlich davor
schweine bzw
Wildschweine fleisch wie schinken oder salami aus den betroffenen ländern mit nach deutschland zu bringen und ich habe es ja eben schon kurz erwähnt
Bislang ist kein impfstoff verfügbar
Und auch in naher zukunft können wir darauf nicht setzen bauern werden jetzt aufgerufen ihre schweine stelle zu sichern
der bauernverband fordert zudem die vorbeugende tötung von etwa
70 prozent des wildschwein bestandes auch von der politik wie etwa der csu wird diese forderung
unterstützt das ist übrigens die bedingungen der european food safety agency also der europäischen agentur für lebensmittelsicherheit
um die schweinepest wirkungsvoll
zu bekämpfen in einigen bundesländern wurden jetzt tatsächlich auch schon die jagd bedingungen erleichtert eben
13.000 erlegte wildschweine in bayern zudem soll noch in diesem monat ein schweinepest krisen gipfel
Stattfinden wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet einfach meine telefonnummer whatsapp
dann
Bekommt ihr die videos vor allen anderen von mir geschickt direkt
Garantiert immer ihr könnt dort über mich in der redaktion von krieg so mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen
Und mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der die
Draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken das ist der direkte link zu meiner nummer und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genauen blogger vergessen hier geht es weiter mit auch dafür draufklicken riesigen todeszone vor der us küste ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran